paysagisme patrimoine bâti design et
métiers d'art tourisme ou encore
gastronomie voici les domaines qui sont
enseignés au campus versailles
patrimoine et artisanat d'excellence le
pilote du projet vient d'être
officiellement inauguré ce lundi 9
novembre à versailles le pilote c'est la
préface on va dire le préfigurateur de
ce que doit être le campus de ce que
devra être le campus à l'horizon 2024 et
puisqu'on est on occupe actuellement en
face du château de versailles la tête de
la grande écurie qui est en face du
château ces 600 m² de plateau qui sont
mises à disposition par le château de
versailles pour travailler sur la voie
professionnelle à terme en 2025 plus de
6000 m² de plateaux seront dédiés au
campus pour l'heure ici deux diplômes
universitaires ont déjà été mis en place
de la forêt au salon et de la terre à la
table objectif couvrir une multitude de
métiers pour affirmer un projet en
traitant de la sylviculture de l'aspect
arboricole du design d'objet de
l'ébénisterie de menuiserie la charpente
donc on voit un maximum de choses dans
cette chaîne de valeur qu'il y ait au
bois pour qu'on puisse pour un étudiant
se positionner sur un projet qu'il
intéressera il ya le monde de
l'agriculture avec
par exemple quand on
l'élève les animaux on va très souvent
aussi au potager du roi qui est pas loin
du tout donc du coup on on avait déterré
des carottes le campus vise également
l'hôtel à projets une partie qui
consiste à répondre à des demandes de
professionnels du château de versailles
ou encore d'enseignants c'est le cas de
ces tables modulable inspiré des jardins
de versailles pour des salles de réunion
ça nous permet donc pour un lieu de
prestige qui est versailles de mettre en
avant aussi notre travail de montrer ce
dont on est capable ce dont les élèves
accompagnés des enseignants sont
capables de réaliser et ça nous permet
aussi d'avoir une expérience avec des
vents à dire des vrais clients la grande
rentrée a lieu le 13 octobre pour cette
première année le campus regroupe une
cinquantaine d'étudiants